Jesus basically says that one of one of
the 12 would betray him
yep and then he he tells them that the
one who he gives he dips bread and uh
yeah gives to will betray him and then
he then gives it to Judas so it seems
pretty clear to me that you know he's
showing Judas is the one who's going to
betray me but then the and then he and
then he tells Judas to do what he must
or to do it quickly but the seem like
they're confused as to what he's talking
about why don't they understand because
you're reading it as an outsider you're
reading it as a narrative and the
details have been filled in for you
because you've already been told before
John 13 Judas is a betrayer in the light
of 2,000 years of Christian tradition
you know who the betrayer is right right
so if you go to John 664 let me walk you
through this because this this is the
problem when we read the Bible we don't
put ourselves in the story and see it
from their perspective you are an
outsider you have a bird's eyee view of
the narrative you already know the end
before you even get there right you know
the end from the beginning yeah
hindsights 2020 that's the whole point
so you got to not read it from that
perspective you got to put yourself and
this is what people need to do honestly
they need to do this and I tell people
put yourself in the story put yourself
in the shoes of the Apostles and see how
you react if these events are unfolding
for the first time before your eyes and
instead of reading it from a bird's eye
view with 2,000 years of church
tradition behind it right so now go to
John 664 and read what we're told so the
narrators has already prepared you that
Judas is the betrayer right but read
John 664 Jesus uh but among you there
are some who do not believe for Jesus
knew from the first who were the ones
that did not believe and who was the one
that would betray him now read John
67-71
Jesus answered them did I not Choose You
the 12 yet one of you is a devil he was
speaking of Judas son of Simon es
scariot for he though one of the TW was
going to betray him so you have the
cheat sheet long before you get to John
13 you've already been told who the
betrayer is right yeah and then if you
go to John 12 read verses 1-1 but focus
on verse six John 12: 1-1 watch here
watch I'm showing you how not to read
The Narrative because you're reading it
with a bird's eye view and not only that
the authors already told you the end
from the beginning because they've
already told you who the betrayer is and
you already know that before you get to
the end Jesus will be killed buried and
be raised to life right right but you
think they knew this as these events are
unfolding Before Their Eyes definitely
not yeah right now read John 12 veres 1-
11 and focus on verse six
where Mary anoints Jesus yeah well just
read it brother I love you not the
subheadings the sub pings are not
inspired
right uh six days before the Passover
Jesus came to Bethany the house of
Lazarus Lazarus whom he had raised from
the dead there they gave a dinner for
him Martha served and Lazarus was one of
those at the table with him Mary took a
pound of costly perfume made of pure
nard anointed jesus' feet and wiped them
with her hair the house was filled with
fragrance of the perfume but Judas a
scariot one of the disciples the one who
was about to betray him said why was so
you see he's already told you again
huh yeah now when John wrote this you
think John knew that when these events
unfolded when he wrote it yeah I mean no
when John wrote this do you think he
knew this when the events were unfolding
before his eyes not writing after the
fact I see what you're saying no he did
not but now he does right hindsight 2020
he's writing after the fact right yeah
okay so now finish it keep
reading said why was this perfume not
sold for 300 dinari and the money given
to the poor he said this not because he
cared about the poor but because he was
a thief he kept the common purse and you
feel uh what was put it so he's a thief
on top of that now you think John knew
that at that time when this was
happening
no because he can't he can't read hearts
or anything like that so thank you and
yet Jesus knew he was a thief Jesus knew
he'd betray him and Jesus knew he was of
the devil yet Jesus still loved him
provided for him cared for him and
empowered him to do a Ministry of
Miracles and never once exposed him and
shamed him and remained faithful in his
love for him till the very
end now with that said now let's go back
to John
13 okay verse two the devil had already
put it into the heart of Judas son of
Simon es scariot to betray him so even
before the end of the chapter you were
told Judas is already been prompted by
the devil now someone asked me was Judas
in control of his decision or was he
prompted by Satan the better question
for that person who asked me that why
would God allow Satan to enter Judas and
control and influence Judas if Judas
hadn't done something blameworthy that
moved God to hand them over to the devil
and other words if God allows the Satan
to take over and God hands you over to
the devil that means you've done
something so Grievous and sinful that
God is now handing you over to the devil
as part of the punishment and judgment
for your wicked evil unrepented sinful
Behavior because someone had asked me
that question so you see that in John 13
verse2 right yeah okay now read for me
verses 18 and 19 John 1318 to19
I'm not
speaking I know whom I have chosen but
it the the one who ate my bread and Has
Lifted his heel against me yeah read it
again because you broke up read 18 and
19 no problem I'm not speaking of all of
you I know whom I have chosen but it is
to fill the scripture the one who ate my
bread Has Lifted his heel against me
okay so
but you caught it right you see how 19
says now I told you before it happens
and when it happens you know I am here
you caught you see all throughout the
narrative you've already been told who
the betrayer is right right all
throughout the
narrative so it's not a surprise for you
that you get it but why should we assume
that the people who are there who are
not Jesus don't know Hearts Don't
Know What Judas is thinking What Judas
is plotting but see Judas as one of
their own why would it surprise you that
they are shocked when Jesus says one of
them would betray him and not getting it
even when Jesus gives them the bread
because in that moment they're in a
State of Shock when you're in a State of
Shock you're not giving your full
undivided
attention yeah right that makes a lot of
sense but now what does that tell you
about the apostles it notice what the
implication is either Judas externally
externally
gave the impression of being such a
devout follower of Jesus Christ that the
other disciples did not even suspect
them for a moment or the other disciples
were so morally compromised like Judas
that they didn't see Judas as any worse
than
them see an implication yeah in other
words what God is showing us through
Judas is that you're going to have
wolves and sheep's clothing that are so
convincing externally that giv such a
convincing
external appearance of being a Christian
that when they do fall you are shocked
for example let's just give a modern
example because it's now public Ravi
Zacharias Ravi zachar you heard of him
right right you see him right the whole
Evangelical world was shocked of his
double life going around imposing
himself on women women paying them for
favors threatening them
and he's been he lived that double life
for years unbeknownst to the world
because the world saw a
sheep but there were people who knew he
was a wolf in sheep's clothing but he
hid it well yeah all right so that's why
they're shocked the disciples because
they're seeing Judas as one of them he's
no better than us he's no worse than us
we're all on the same level so when he
says one of you betray me I'll give even
that act of giving the bread because
they're in a State of Shock when
something shocking happens you get this
combobulated and you're not giving your
full attention and you may not
understand what you're seeing before you
because of the
shock and that's why you see everyone is
it me is it me they're freaking out
right yeah and they also probably didn't
understand exactly what G the exact
moment of betrayal that Jesus was
referring to because they didn't
necessarily expect him to be handed over
to be crucified right yeah no that they
they did not think Messiah was going to
be killed and then rise on the third day
but the whole point is when he says one
of you will betray me understand first
thing was shock and fear and horror and
Dread so they're not thinking about
they're not thinking about the
implication is it me is even when he
says the one I give they're still in a
State of Shock And if you've ever gone
through uh traumatic
experiences life changing traumatic
experiences you understand that in that
moment shock takes in you are now
discombobulated and you're not fully
aware or Co cognizant of your
surrounding and that's what happened to
them for their Messiah to say when are
you going to betray me complete shock
their system just shut down they were
discombobulated they were in a state of
just confusion that's why even when he
gave the sign they still didn't figure
it out that's just human behavior that's
common sense in other words the Bible is
giving you a realistic portrayal of
human experience and emotion and how
human beings react at certain events
especially Earth shattering traumatic
events yeah so that's what you're
reading in John 13 I appreciate it
another another uh just a quick di note
that I remember reading a it's a Mystic
commentary um
on uh the when Judas received uh the
Eucharist really um that's the moment
that Satan had entered into him yeah um
most likely yes I can't say no uh
because this is taking place at the
upper room where they're reclining at
table and Jesus is celebrating the
Passover and he's already told them this
bread which is broken is my body broken
for you and this cup is the New Covenant
in my blood shed for for you right so
yeah it's it's yeah so and Judas was
there he partook of it so it is
likely that Satan was well not likely
you're already told Satan was already
prompting him right right and but in
John
1327 we're told he now enters him John
13:27 read that again uh after he
received the the piece of bread or in
the do RS I think it's like the morsel
of bread yes Satan entered into him see
so Satan entered when he now what's
interesting if you read the verse John
13:27 it says what you do what you're
about to do do quickly now it's singular
if you read it in the Greek it's
singular he's talking to one so now the
question is is who's he talking to Judas
or Satan who had entered
him um that's interesting isn't it
that's very interesting is he telling
Satan do what you're about to do quickly
or Judas because the word again you
can't tell in your English but if you
read the Greek it's singular and the
King James brings out the Dy Rees brings
it out because it shows you that the
pronoun is singular it's thou yeah th
right what translation are you reading I
think it's the new revised Standard
Version yeah you don't have the Dewey
Reigns or the King James with you I
don't have it on me so I can't I I
always use it online I don't have a copy
of okay well you can confirm you'll see
it's singular he's speaking to one so is
he talking to Judas or is he giving
Satan permission go ahead and use Judas
to betray me and do it
quickly the reason why I ask the
question because the Bible is quite
clear that Satan has to be given
permission authorization to do anything
because if God doesn't authorize it then
Satan is hindered because Satan is a
finite temporal creature on God's leash
he can only do what God permits him to
do and this is confirmed in Luke 22
31-32 if you go to Luke 22 3132 you'll
see it here uh our brother Protestant
believer who's staying up late God bless
you brother he just posted the Dewey
Reigns notice it notice the pronoun guys
and after the morsel Satan entered him
and Jesus said to him that which
thou th and Elizabethan English is
singular would that that which thou Dost
do quickly thou is singular he's talking
to one now if you go to Luke 22
31-32 Luke 22
31-32 see what happens
there see 31 to 31- 32 yep Simon Simon
listen Satan has demanded to all of you
like wheat but I have prayed for you
that your own faith may not fail and you
when once you have turned back
strengthen your brothers and uh that's
the end yeah sorry we uh we were
buffering read it again my internet was
buffering read it one more time brother
Simon Simon listen Satan has demanded to
shft all of you like we but I have
prayed for you that your own faith may
not fail and you when once you have
turned back strengthen your brothers
okay not say to
ask and get permission authorization to
sift you separate the wheat from the
chaff and so the Lord's response shows
that Satan has been given that
authorization but then the Lord says I
prayed for you Simon and now notice what
the Lord did not say but I prayed for
you Simon if you are no no when now
notice the Assurance if Jesus is praying
for you his prayer is all powerful it's
not a matter of if it's a matter of when
if he's praying for for you know that
his prayers are answered and they don't
go unheeded so if you prays there is
nothing more powerful in the world than
the Son of God praying for you because
his prayer is answered
always so I hope that answered your
question brother